hello and welcome to see you're playing
Claudio man from Italy okay maybe we get
some Kings Indian still yep from my age
three line and see what happens ya black
ass opening up the center here I hope
that long term my c4 evil pawns provide
nice space advantage Jim 25 is not a big
deal i have Knight f3 he's double
attacking bishop at night but doesn't
really do much yeah I think here black
should probably take my bishop just to
trade some some things here he's got
less space and some trades help him
taking a longer time out okay here i can
I want to move the bishop clearly but
where I can go to F 1 or 2 C 2 I think
c2 maybe turn keep em we form covered
age of 6 gallon to Bishop f4 right and
attacking the d6 pawn it looks okay just
keep it simply i attack the pawn and
prepare the centralization maybe I could
have played knight c6 already here is
that is that really the case no we are
screened e8 at the end 96b takes bishop
26 28 and my bishop is pinned but I can
I can't threaten that now are
threatening 90 x e6
okay that's that's interesting here a
couple of tactics around the corner here
students to be formed if he goes to
e6000 I'd f5 and even here night f5 is
an interesting move txt eggs threatening
f6 mmm interesting night f5 takes TX we
never 694 yeah okay let's go for it if
it's not working c'est la vie
well it looks pretty dangerous if you
ask me
yeah so if i take with the Queen that's
Queen f6 so f6 check
and then Queen d3 right Jeff f6 check
King h8 can also take its own app that
wins the exchange at the end but queen
bee three right has made made on age
seven
no as no defense the queen is also
hanging with rook takes e7 not just pawn
takes its own
no not nothing to do anymore
black resigned okay I think might have
five look cute I think it works but
let's uh let's have a look at a couple
of situation cm okay here age six are
here already night at five wins for
Bishop t6 am I saw that idea a little
bit too late right Black is falling
apart Ian now it's not no it's not
working anymore because i saw this idea
always like this but he can go here and
now i cannot take because the queen is
all red queen is hanging but ok this and
now Knight a5 is already working i was
thinking you know I saw the move but I
thought that here he still I wanted 94
and I have 94 this is why I played be
four first but here i can go here and
and still win as there should be seven
is terrible while what a bad position
but that's this is also not bad he can
defend now though at least not losing
immediately with this yeah okay and this
is a this is in fact a win chan is this
Queen d3 end cannot cannot defend this
ya hear the Queen has attacked and
whatever you do I mean here that's
nighty for this is what by a play before
first and now no no
f6 should should do the trick Queenie 2
is also strong check for example and all
kinds of things are hanging d 6 and so
on yeah if we trace this a little bit
back I think here instead of see 6 I
think you should take this and then and
go from here maybe Bishop d7 or
something like that I mean you probably
are not surprised if I say that I like
right here because of the big space
advantage but something like that is
probably what he has to do this son
looks really uncomfortable the point is
weak and there's no no clear counter
plane okay well thanks for watching